قبل الحصاد كنت قد اجيت مقابله مع الدكتور
انتوني فوتشي المستشار الطبي الاول للرئيس
الامريكي ومدير المعهد الوطني للحساسيه
والامراض المعديه سالته اولا عن تحذيره من
متحور جديد قد يجعل هذا الشتاء صعبا
واضرار
للبيئه الاصليه خمسه واربعين التي نقلق
بشانها في الولايات المتحده وفي العالم
احدها بي كيو بوينت 1 والثاني بي كيو بوي
اكبر من المتحورات الاصليه وهي قد تتغلب
على المقاومه وتنتشر بطريقه اكثر كفاءه من
بي اي خمسه واربعين من حسن الحظ ان
الجرعات المتاحه الان للتقويه تملك القدره
على ان تحفز الرد الذي يحمينا منها ولهذا
السبب من المهم تلقي اللقاح وعلى من لم
يحصل على جراحه المعززه ان يحصل عليها
ما هي توصيتكم لمواجهه متحور جديد في ال
ال الشتاء المقبل
هي ان يتلقى اكبر عدد من الناس اللقاح لان
الفرق في العدوى والانتقال و نسبه الوفاه
اكبر بكثير لدى من لم يتلقى اللقاح مقارنه
بالذين تلقوه وهذا سبب وجيه بينما ندخل
للاشهر البارده في اواخر فصل الخريف
والشتاء بان نواكب مستجدات اللقاح
العالميه قال قبل فتره ان العالم اقرب من
اي وقت مضى للقضاء على وباء كورونا همم
اذا ما قررنا هذا الكلام مع ما تقوله انت
الان عن احتماليه وجود متحور جديد كيف
نفهم هذا
حسنا اطلاقا بين وجهتين نظر لان المدير
العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه محيط اذا
نظرنا الى وضعنا الان مقارنه بالعام
الماضي عندما ظهر او ميكرون للمره الاولى
فالان نحن في وضع الافضل بكثير رغم ان
هناك متحورات جديده الا ان مستوى العدوى
اقل بكثير عن العام الماضي في نفس الوقت
نقوم بجهود اكثر والكثير من الناس يتلقونا
لقاح مثلا عندما كان اميرون في ذروته في
الولايات المتحده كان هناك تقريبا من
800,000 الى 900,000 اصابه وعدى جديده
يوميا وكذلك من ثلاثه الاف الى اربعه الاف
حاله وفاه اليوم لدينا من 350 الى 400
حاله وفاه رغم هذا نعتقد انه مستوى غير
مقبول ونريده ان يقل اكثر كلنا نواجه
التحدي بوجود متحورات جديده لكن كما ذكرت
لدينا عالميه دوليه للوقايه من هذه
المتحورات وهذا عن طريق الحرص على تلق
اللقاح
دكتور
19 طويل الاجل هل يشكل تحديات اضافيه
بنسبه لكم
المدى وهذه قضيه مهمه جدا لانه على سبيل
المثال في الولايات المتحده وهي بلد كبير
بكثافه سكانيه عاليه لدينا تقريبا من سبعه
الى 15 مليون شخص مصاب بكوفه طويل الاجل
وهو عباره عن استمرار للاعراض لاسابيع او
لاشهر بعد التعافي من المرحله الحاده
للمرض ولدينا مليون شخص غير قادر على
العمل بسبب تاثرهم بذلك لذلك نحن نركز على
هذا الامر ويعتبر متلازمه غامضه لاننا لا
نعرف كل الاليات المتعلقه به لكننا ندرسه
عن كثب لنرى ان كنا قادرين على منعه او
التعامل معه ومعالجه المصابين به
الدكتور لماذا تعتبر بانه يجب التعامل مع
جدري القرده بشكل اكثر صرامه
لاننا نريد ان نضمن الا ينتشر بشكل اكبر
فهو قضيه المتفاعله والان لدينا تقريبا
28,000 شخص في الولايات المتحده مصاب
بجدري القرده نريد ان نضمن السيطره على
هذا المرض بتقديم الادويه واللقاح من
المهم جدا التعامل مع هذا المرض لانه خارج
افريقيا ينتشر بين الرجال الذين يمارسون
الجنس مع الرجال ونريد تنبيها هذه الفئه
اما جداريه القرده ينتشر بينهم ونريدهم ان
يتلقوا اللقاح لانه متوفر دكتور السؤال
الاخير ربما ينتشر الان ما يعرف بالار اس
بي الفيروسات التنفسيه ويدخل الكثير من
الاطفال الى المستشفيات وربما الى العنايه
الفائقه هل بعد الجائحه وبعد التباعد
الاجتماعي لفتره طويله اصبحنا اكثر عرضه
للاصابه بالفيروسات التنفسيه
احدى المشكلات انه عندما كان الكثيرون
يرتدون الكمامه ويتباعدون اجتماعيا انخفضت
الكثير من الامراض التنفسيه والتلاشت الان
يخرج الناس ولا يستخدمون الكمامات
ويشاركون في مناسبات اجتماعيه لذلك نشهد
زياده في هذه الامراض وهي امراض نراها في
منتصف الشتاء لكن بدنا نراها الان في
منتصف الخريف حتى قبل قدوم الشتاء هذا امر
مقلق جدا لان الفيروسات المسببه
الالتهابات الجهاز التنفسي قد تكون خطيره
على الاطفال دون خمس سنوات وعلى المسنين
لذلك يجب ان نتعامل معها بشكل حذر ونستخدم
كل الاجراءات الاحترازيه التي نستخدمها مع
سائر الامراض التنفسيه
والامراض المعديه المستشار الطبيه الاول
للرئيس الامريكي شكرا لك
اجنبي